Podcast heterogeneity and resistance
mechanisms in advanced prostate cancer
by dr. raul PFC Jung I'm Christina jewel
and elaborate and I'll be your moderator
for today's event lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
site and we are proud to bring you this
interactive web seminar for more
information visit us at lab Lutz com
here's how the presentation works we
want to hear from you questions comments
and even answers can be submitted via
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of your screen will try to get everyone
but if not we will make sure to follow
up with you by e-mail you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen right on on the lower right hand
of the corner of the slide window if you
can't see or hear this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right of the
Q&A button or in the lower left this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
CD button located at the bottom left
hand corner of your web page and follow
the process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Raul as conception dr.
concep seond is the current director of
the comprehensive of State Center in
Nashville dr. conception was a general
surgery and urology resident at
Vanderbilt University of Medicine from
1984 1989 he served as chief urology
resident from nineteen eighty nine to
nineteen ninety and was also a research
fellow in the light laboratories at
Vanderbilt he's been in practice since
1990 with his major clinical interesting
urologic oncology specializing in
advanced prostate and bladder cancer and
lower urinary tract reconstruction he
has an academic appointment of him
Vanderbilt school of medicine as
associate clinical professor department
of urology he is board certified by the
american urological association the aua
and is a member of that organization as
well as the southeastern section of the
AE way Society of our logic oncology
American College of surgeon and the
Nashville church
gical society I would like to introduce
dr. confezione dr. concep SIA great
Kirsty thank you so much and welcome
everyone this morning thanks for joining
us so for the next hour so we're going
to talk about the heterogeneity and
resistance mechanisms and patients with
advanced prostate cancer these are my
current disclosures as of today and this
is a really germane topic as you know
the number of advances have been made
over the past six years relative to the
therapeutics as well as the diagnosis
and multiple modalities imaging etc for
advancing prostate cancer so this is
sort of your typical data for 2016 we
estimate that number of new cases will
be down probably around 190,000 much of
that is related as many of you may know
to the United States Preventive Services
Task Force recommendation that if that
has given PSA ad recommendation which is
a whole nother topic but so prostate
cancer as you know is the leading cause
of solid tumor and men over the age of
50 and the number below the 27,000 desk
directly attributable to prostate cancer
we know that prostate cancer is the
second leading cause of cancer specific
death in men over the age of 50 behind
lung cancer so as we look at prostate
cancer it is really a spectrum of
disease and as urologist we generally
deal with localized disease because
patients get referred to us for
elevations of their PSA we offer
definitive therapy historically speaking
radiation therapy surgical therapy we
can do cryo and now for many prostate
cancers appropriately prostate cancer
patients appropriately selected active
surveillance also is very appropriate
however we know that a certain number of
people despite definitive therapy will
develop this basically this biochemical
occurrence
and what we mean by that is that their
PSAs will start to rise and once that
happens that generally pretends to a
worsening situation and patients then
usually get started on hormonal therapy
but at that point they can actually
migrate into two areas one is where we
know that patients actually become
metastatic before they're even started
on hormones and the other one is when
they develop this concept of
castration-resistant prostate cancer
which by definition means prostate
cancer on hormonal therapy testosterone
levels less than 50 and rising PSA so
this is sort of that hypothetical
journey many of you have seen probably
iterations of this slide in that what
generally happens is that once we once
we start hormonal therapy when the PSA
starts to go up whether this the
castration whether it be a surgically
bilateral orchiectomy or whether it be
medical therapy usually androgen
deprivation therapy what you see is a
diminution in their PSA but then
historically what will happen in a
percentage of patients is that you will
start the PSA again will start to rise
this is where urologist we need to be
more diligent in in terms of trying to
manage these patients trying to identify
metastatic disease because right now the
beauty about it is that we have multiple
therapies that we can give first second
third line to out in these patients that
develop metastatic disease so this what
we're going to do is really talk about
more than molecular mechanisms and we
talked about heterogeneity this is not
unique to prostate cancer but probably
most tumors did exhibit some element of
heterogeneity and by heterogeneity we
can discuss between patient to patient
within the patient him skimmer hurt
herself and obviously prostate is going
to be himself but even within the tumor
itself so let me give you examples of
some heterogeneity so this is from
patient the patient and what this slide
depicts is that these are studies doing
30 rapid autopsy sampling of patients
who basically passed from
castration-resistant prostate cancer and
basically over here on the left-hand
side of your screen what you're seeing
is that depending upon the patient they
can develop metastatic disease
historically we've always fought about
prostate cancer the majority of it does
go to bone which we know secondarily we
know it does go to lymph nodes but you
can see it can actually spread through a
number of these different organs and
again this is representative of 30
different patients all dying of
castration-resistant prostate cancer on
the right side of your screen really
within the same patient within the same
metastatic sites you see different era
different differentiation different
histopathology characteristics within
the same patient based upon metastatic
disease and also what you also see is
that you get different expression of the
androgen receptor which we'll talk about
more so again that is the heterogeneity
as we just as we did as we define
between patient to patient however
within the tumor itself you can actually
see heterogeneity again you can get some
areas here that have rapid that has a
lot of staining of the the androgen
receptor and have also have a
differentiation of abstaining for
templates to earth and again what you
see here again within the same patient
within the same patient here again all
with all of prostate cancer within the
tumor itself we get high expression of
androgen receptor but in the lymph node
the metastatic site you actually get low
expression of the antigen say and that's
variable from patient to patient now
this is a very important slide and I
want you to recognize as that as you
know when we do biopsies for patients
than prostate cancer we have
historically woefully underestimated
under sample the prostate and so what
this slide depicts is that most is
if you do your biopsy and you hit one of
these green clones over here you may
mistakenly think well that's the primary
clone that's what's that's what's
happening within the entire prostate but
lo and behold what can actually happen
is that there can be a small subclone
which you may not even recognize that
actually is going to be decide
ultimately of metastatic disease so
again this is this is heterogeneity
within the primary tumor itself and so
again we you know this is not unique to
prostate cancer this is probably true
for most tumors this slide is also very
interesting again this is rapid autopsy
basically with patients who have who
have passed and prostate cancer and what
we see here is we get polyclonal seating
so in the left part of this screen what
you see here is that and again this Liz
they did pan tomek sequencing on
patients who had passed away from
metastatic castration-resistant prostate
cancer and what you see here is that
from particular clones you get extension
you get seeding of one clone into the
seminal vesicles and in the lymph nodes
and then from that seating you get
branching into various areas outside the
pelvis but then once but then from there
you can also get this very complex array
of cross seating and what's actually
what was presented last year at prostate
cancer foundation is that some of this
exceeding can actually go back down and
reseed the prostate which makes us now
really rethink about how aggressive we
need to be with the primary tumor even
in the setting of metastatic disease and
so and so what we also know is that
basically depending upon the site of
seeding depending upon where basically
metastatic disease is being detected
will actually have prognostic
implications and we so we based upon
this slide we know that patients who
have with lymph node metastasis only
generally enjoy a longer overall
survival advantage versus patients who
have bone and certainly those who have a
common
the bone and visceral disease so there
are two really models that are out there
for the development of
castration-resistant prostate cancer one
is what we call this adaption model
which is what you have within the
primary tumor is that you have clones
that are sensitive to androgen debt to
hormonal therapy and then once we start
androgen deprivation therapy again
whether that be by bilateral orchiectomy
or medical therapy you basically wipe
out these hormonal II sensitive clowns
but then what is left are these other
clones that tend to be that are
inherently resistant to androgen
deprivation therapy and then you get an
expansion of those particular clones
that result in advancement of the
disease so that's the adaption month or
excuse me that's the selection model
then the adaption model is really one
where what you have probably this is a
combination of the two is that you have
basically clones that are all sensitive
to androgen deprivation therapy and then
once you institute androgen deprivation
therapy once you alter the micro tumor
environment then what happens is that
you get that development of cells that
acquire additional features whether it
be mutation epigenetic changes that then
R is that then render them resistant to
traditional androgen deprivation therapy
resulting in a clonal expansion of
resistant cells and again what this
slide depicts is that for the most part
we know historically that note that the
androgen receptor continues to play a
major role in the development of
metastatic castration-resistant prostate
cancer but we also know that there are a
are independent mechanisms and will
actually expand on this so that's why
because of this continued dependence
upon the Energon receptors we have
changed the nomenclature from what
historically has been called androgen
and sensitive hormonal II resistant to
this concept of castration resistant
prostate cancer this is the sentinel
article that was published back in the
in the 40s the plugins in Hodges lot who
many of you know won the Nobel Prize
they were they were the only two year
all of dis clin Nobel Prize and
basically they found that prostate
cancer was a hormonal eager than disease
now what we know now again is this
concept of the image intercepting if you
would have told me seven or eight years
ago that as a urologist we would have to
be fully cognizant fully aware of the
androgen receptor in order to treat
advancing prostate cancer I would have
said well that's not going to be that
relevant but again I am I am I really
pushing for those of you out there that
want to manage advanced prostate cancel
it is incredibly important to understand
the molecular components of the end
we've intercepted so this is a schematic
looking at the AR so we know that the AR
is coded for on chromosomal chromosome
11 on the X chromosome and really what
it what it has it actually has four
major functional domains so again so it
starts out here as a again this is basic
this is basic DNA RNA transcription
translation so it starts out on a number
of X exons on the 11th on chromosome 11
which results in to basically
transcription you into messenger RNA and
so the protein itself the actual
hindered interceptor which is a function
of translation has four distinct regions
one is what we call the n terminus and
basically this area is responsible for
the majority of transcription activity
you also have this DNA binding domain
which is responsible also for
transcription when you get nuclear
translocation in between the DNA binding
domain has enma ligand binding domain is
actually this area called the hinge
region which is responsible for nuclear
translocation of the antigen receptor
but the fourth area which is really
important to understand is this like in
binding domain and the ligand binding
no name basically is coded for the exons
four through eight this is the area that
actually will bind the androgen will
bind dihydrotestosterone which is a much
more powerful Hamilton it starts the
whole mechanism so again this is sort of
the canonical pathway that we that we
talked about many of you know this but
it's always good to to rehash this so
what happens is that you get you get
testosterone that's circulating either
bound or free when it's bound it's
usually bound to sex hormone-binding log
in you dissociate the testosterone from
sex hormone-binding blah blah you then
have diffusion of testosterone from the
extracellular space into the
intracellular space once inside the
intracellular space testosterone is
converted to dihydrotestosterone which
again is a much much more powerful
antigen by an enzyme called 5-alpha
reductase within the within the
cytoplasm of the prostate cell you have
the androgen receptor the androgen
receptor usually has a chaperone
molecule usually heat shock protein once
again once it sees three free androgen
you get disassociation of heat shock
protein of the chaperone molecule and
you get binding of the androgen to that
ligand binding domain that results in
dimerization of the receptor complex you
get then he trip a nuclear translocation
into the nucleus you then get binding of
the receptor ligand complex via the DNA
binding domain to DNA which then starts
the process of transcription to
messenger RNA and then to translation
and because of that because of this
process because of this androgen driven
event what pops out or a series of
proteins PSA actually being one of them
it's very important to understand that
but also that was that also results in
prosthetic cell growth and survival so
again this is what we call the canonical
pathway and again it is all driven by
the antigen
and so prostate cancer again the what we
recognize is that it continues to rely
on antigen signalling binding androgen
signaling so again as we look down here
this is again the whole the whole
pathway again but what we know is that
there are numerous adaptive mechanisms
that despite manipulating the androgen
accents whether it be by lowering
testosterone or binding up the androgen
receptor with hand with androgen
receptor inhibitors you have all these
different pathways in which the cell
which the prostate cancer cell can
continue to survive continue to evade
off a pop ptosis which results in
projection of the disease and so again
this is sort of this slide that we
showed earlier is that they are androgen
receptor they are there are a are
independent mechanisms and then there
are a are dependent mechanisms and we'll
go through these because this would this
can this usually then is how we
understand the various targets so if you
really want to start looking at this
from a from a genomic standpoint this
was an article that was published in the
Journal of Clinical Oncology and I it's
a great review article is from the folks
help with the University of Michigan a
rule Shania and many of you probably saw
this that was published in cell last
year and this was funded by prostate
cancer foundation and the stand up to
cancer and again these are very good
review articles that talks about the
molecular pathways in the in the
importance of clinical genomics um what
they found then again easily this is
these were biopsies in the end these
were patients had passed away from
castration-resistant prostate cancer 150
patients they did pay an ohmic
sequencing and what they find is that
there is a number of driver aberrations
that they identify through the through
genomic sequencing so on the left hand
side here you see a number of what these
aberration is all you get somatic
mutations gene fusion
is homozygous deletions androgen
receptor amplifications and what's
becoming more and more important now
there was a recent article in the New
England Journal of Medicine about the
possibility of these germline mutations
especially as it relates to DNA repair
mechanisms so these are all the driver
of aberrations on the left and then
these are the potentially actionable
mutations that we actually see and much
of them involved AAR amplification or
mutations pi3k but again a lot of
attention is going to be paid with these
DNA repair mechanisms so again so we get
getting back to this concept of
heterogeneity we know that you can get
genetic alteration genetic alterations
to drug targets and remember a lot of
the targets right now in terms of the
newer medications are the star
developing towards the image and
receptor so when you heat so when you
look at you trying to look at particular
targets you can kind of break them up to
drugs that will actually decrease the
natto of circulating testosterone the
definitive article by hugginson objects
so we've known about lhrh analogs
whether they be agonist or antagonists
that will actually cut down the levels
of circulating testosterone we want
patients to have testosterone levels
less than 50 there are also ways to
basically influence that relative to
looking at increasing sex
hormone-binding blah blah and as well as
trying to decrease free testosterone
secondary targets could be specifically
looking at the less than five percent of
testosterone production that comes from
the adrenal gland and again when you
look at the various ways to do that
historically in the past we have used
ketoconazole which is an antifungal that
now you have a whole number of different
agents of the one that obviously many
people are using that's commercially
approved is a Beretta
acetate uh then there's these other cops
then the other targets could be actually
where we're actually trying to take out
the androgen receptor itself so we can
we can go after trying to look at things
that alter the chaperone molecules as I
talked about this is heat shock protein
as well as salt as well as agents that
will down regulate the antigen receptor
itself then you can auction then again
this is this is an area that that a lot
of attention has been paid to over the
years is this is basically blocking the
image and receptive so we know that
historically the first generation anti
androgens were flew to my bicalutamide
malouda my one that was approved in 2012
in both the pre chemo and post
chemotherapy space is enzalutamide but
then you also have a number of others in
development specifically a RN 509 it's
now known as a polluter mine you have
agents that you can try to block the
nuclear translocation again we we are
fully aware that enzalutamide actually
may do that but what you also what we
what we are aware of is that your your
traditional site of talks and
chemotherapies your micro tubulin
inhibitors one of its mechanistic
actions may actually be preventing of
the nuclear translocation of the
receptor ligand complex then you can
interfere with androgen receptor
enablers you can block co-activators and
then you can also try to take out the
downstream effects again this is going
to be a whole area of increased
mechanistic actions and drug development
looking at pi3 kinase and for inhibitors
etc so these are all again these are all
the potential ways to specifically look
at targeting the image and receptive and
again this is a very complex slide but
here on the right what you're seeing
here again is sort of a summary but
potentially everything that we talked
about within the
previous he slides so just some
specifics of some certain mutations that
have been identified recently this was
an article back in cell in 2013 where
they actually found that there was a
gain of function in dihydrotestosterone
synthesis to remember
dihydrotestosterone is a byproduct of
the conversion of testosterone to
dihydrotestosterone body by the enzyme
5-alpha reductase so whenever we lower
circulating testosterone weather usually
again that be castration we are seeing a
lowering of dihydrotestosterone what
this article and then this came out of
the group at the southwestern is that
what they are able to find is that you
can actually get not Hydra
dihydrotestosterone synthesis through
and other enzymatic reaction that's not
using testosterone as the preclusive
this is another this is another study
looking at epigenetic mechanisms in
terms of its role in androgen receptor
positive this is a this is an article
that was published beginning in cell
where they found that you can get
activation of the antigen receptor
complex not by again not by the
testosterone mechanism but actually
through the glucocorticoid yourself and
what makes this important is that one of
the agents as you know that we currently
use to block androgen synthesis actually
requires the co-administration of other
glucocorticoid and again based upon this
article that actually may confer some
element of resistance as well again
getting back to the heterogeneity
induced mechanisms of action so we
talked about genetic alterations to the
antigen receptor we also talked about
the expression of multidrug-resistant
pumps and all end as well as areas to
evade a pop ptosis so in terms of
multidrug-resistant pumps you know that
there are a flux pumps there are a flux
protein
plants that actually can confer
resistance to certain therapeutic agents
specifically chemotherapeutic agents and
so we know that looking at messenger RNA
that some of these proteins actually
have over expression and those those
those cells that have increased over
expression of that protein are going to
be more highly chemo resistant to many
of us cytotoxic agents in terms of those
in terms of mechanisms to evade a pop
ptosis we know that you can have altered
micro RNA expression and ultra Chaplin
expression so micro RNAs are small RNA
marled molecules that target specific
messenger RNAs and can prevent
expression of targeted genes so again if
they're preventing expression of
targeted genes and protein than if you
get dysregulation or you get where you
get an increased amount of this micro
RNA that can actually lead to chemo
resistant cells because you all you are
preventing the translation of beats on
these targeted proteins and again this
lyssa this was an article came out of
Dana Farber that actually looked at that
you can have altered chaperone molecule
expression this is really a lot of work
that this gun was done in the Vancouver
prostate Institute prostate Center
looking at a drug looking at an agent
called plus them as we discussed what
happens is that the androgen receptor
usually is bound by in the cytoplasm by
the staff alone molecule molecules so
clustering is a molecule chaperone that
has multiple roles and overexpression of
clusterin is a potential mechanism for
invasion of a pop ptosis plus current
activity has been implicated in
chemoresistance so what they're trying
to do is target clustering to hopefully
again reduce the amount of
chemoresistance that can be acquired so
again what this Skinner this this whole
area of resistance is becoming more and
more of interest with becoming an
increase in problem so when we talk
about again this whole concept of
castration
resistant prostate cancer I want
everybody to be very familiar with what
this what this means so again for
castration-resistant prostate cancer
it's a patient that has diagnosis of
prostate cancer is on androgen
deprivation therapy now whether that be
monotherapy using and using lhrh
agonists or bilateral orchiectomy or
whether that be complete androgen
blockade using an ADT plus first
generation antigen receptor inhibitors
uh it doesn't really know but they have
to be on androgen deprivation therapy
testosterone level less than 50 we can
have a whole other discussion whether it
should be less than 30 less than 20 less
than 10 I think most of us believe below
is it better however despite having
castration levels of testosterone the
PSA stuff to go up and again these are
the areas these are the patients that
are usually seen by the urologist
they're asymptomatic but when the PSA
starts to go up I believe we as
urologist we need to be more diligent of
looking for a writ of looking for
metastatic disease so you will hear
people talk about m0 and m1 disease so
the definition when I talk about m0
castration-resistant prostate cancer
it's basically patients that meet the
definition of CRP see they are studied
and lo and behold usually using
traditional bone scan or CT there's no
evidence of radium radiographic Midtown
metastatic disease so that is m0 disease
problem is is that m0 disease we all
know where these patients are going
because usually within two years they
will actually progress to m1 disease and
again m1 disease means that they meet
the definition of castration-resistant
prostate cancer below and behold when
you imaging when you image them using CT
or bone scan or if you're fortunate
fortunate enough to be able to obtain
sodium fluoride pet choline or possibly
some of the newer agents the newly
approved amino acids
nfa cbc or if you live in an area where
you can get polling you get you get
identification of metastatic sites and
so again this concept of m0 disease
really is an unmet need in prostate
cancer and again I believe that that m0
disease we will probably see less and
less of this as we start to utilize as
more advanced imaging becomes available
so the problem with m0 disease currently
is that none of the agents that are
currently approved for m1 disease are
actually approved in the m0 space so
when you look at a UA or nccn guidelines
what is approved in the m0 space is
clinical trial or observation now there
are a number of there are a number of
instant there a number of sponsor
induced sponsors sponsored trials that
are currently underway that are looking
at utilization of therapeutic agents
enzalutamide apple utam ID and odm 201
within this m0 space so this is really
an unmet meet and as many of you know
since 2010 what we've had is a slew of
therapies that have been approved since
the original approval of docetaxel in
2004 there are none there have been a
number of p clinical trials some of them
have been posited some of them and
negative and again this is a summary of
all the of all the drugs that have been
approved since 2010 so docetaxel was the
first agent that was approved in 2004
and that aisle with an increase in
median survival of two point six to two
point nine months Jeff tana of kibazo
taxol was approved in 20 2011 with a
survival benefit of two point four
months then you have a greater own
acetate or zytiga that was approved in
the post chemotherapy and in the pre
chemotherapy space followed by
enzalutamide again in the post chemo
include chemotherapy space
followed by radium-223 so as many of you
know agora Tyrone acetate is an androgen
synthesis inhibitor enzalutamide as I
enzalutamide Oryx Tandy is an antigen
receptor signaling inhibitor and
radium-223 is an alpha emitter alpha
emitting radiopharmaceutical so since
2016 where we've been again this is this
area is expanding so where we've been
prior prior to 2010 is that we've had
one drug approved which was docetaxel
but then since 2010 we've had five newly
approved agents the problem that that we
have is that all those trials that I
that I mentioned in the prior slide were
all monotherapy trials so we have a real
knowledge gap if you will in terms of
optimal timing and use of these agents
in combination in layering or in
sequencing one of the things that we've
talked about and many of you have
probably heard about this and what we
call these antigen receptors spliced
bearings and again that's why I really
stress the trust stress the concept of
the understanding of the androgen
receptor and so in review again the
androgen receptor has four distinct
areas it's got this n-terminal DNA
n-terminal domain which is which results
in transcript transcription you get this
DNA binding domain that was that that
comes into play when you get nuclear
translocation of the androgen receptor
complex into this into the nucleus you
get this hinge region that's that helps
with nuclear translocation but again in
exons forth that's coded for by exons 5
through a 43 when you get this like in
binding but what a number of scientists
and researchers have have found is that
you get this you get these variations
really much
this is due to treat impression
selection so the one that's gotten a lot
of attention recently is basically what
we call the ARV seven slice very so the
androgen receptors spot the ARV seven
splice variant again if this is the
full-length AR and again what is
important is this live in binary new
mate so when review the ligand binding
domain is what binds within the
cytoplasm that's where the
dihydrotestosterone basically sits on
the receptive what we have found is that
it was that in this AR v7 splice variant
is that the ligand binding domain blocks
out so you would think okay that would
be a good thing because if it can't bind
ligand if it can't bind
dihydrotestosterone or testosterone then
it should shut down the energy
interceptor and lo and behold what they
have found is that unfortunately um you
can actually get the receptors still
stays active despite not being not
binding like it and so we think this is
this is an area that is really brought
on by the use this treatment pressure
selection utilizing a lot of the agents
that we're talking about in terms of
that manipulating and who can access so
many of you have seen this data this
would this came out of Johns Hopkins
this was a manual anton offices data
that was presented a couple years ago at
ASCO as well as the au lait and
published in the new england journal of
medicine and what that and what the
group at hopkins did is that they took
patients who had been treated with
abiraterone or enzalutamide or naive and
they tested them using circulating using
circulating tumor cells for the presence
of the arv seven splice berry and lo and
behold what they found is that if you
were if you were a rv7 positive here
again what happens is that these
patients they it drops the lag in x
be dooming but if you're a rv7 positive
and then you get treated with a androgen
access modulator manipulator whether it
be whether you're trying to use
abiraterone acetate or enzalutamide you
basically have no PS a response which
makes sense because again what
abiraterone can enzalutamide they are
manipulating the antigen access by
either dropping out testosterone or
binding up the antigen receptor and
enzalutamide or even a polluted mine has
to bind to that ligand binding domain so
there's no binding domain for it to act
on then or even if you have a decrease
in circulating testosterone the drugs
aren't going to have an effect and
therefore that's why patients that are
exhibiting that a rv7 mutation really
won't respond but then if you look at
what happens if they AR v seven- where
the where the ligand binding domain is
intact then you obviously see a very
impressive result in PSA response and
then when you look at basically response
in terms of radiographic
progression-free survival as you might
expect patients who are a rv7 positive
really having more rep much more rapid
progress and again this is basically
whether you were treated with
enzalutamide or abiraterone you see the
basically the same tab so patients that
exhibited the AR AR v 7 negative across
the board whether or not it was
abiraterone oral is enzalutamide
basically responding had a better
response to therapy um so we know that
two-thirds of patients with metastatic
castration-resistant prostate cancer
have tumors with intermediate or four
resistance to a are targeting agents so
again you can actually follow this
clinically and
this is sort of again how I think you
should look at it so you can have
primary existence intermediate
resistance and a are sensitive so what
generally what I look at when when I
said when I clinically start patients on
some of the androgen access modulators
basically I try to check their PSA is
quite regularly during the first three
months and so what happens is that you
can predict that a very a are sensitive
what you are going to see if you look at
the y axis which is PSA decline those
that are a are sensitive generally will
have a very rapid reduction yeah in the
Indian agenda septum however again just
as we have really have looked at from
the antenna raucous data what's going to
happen is that these patients that are
that are intermediate intermediately
resistant what you may see is a drop
initially but with time with continued
therapy that you will then see a rise in
the PSA you are going to have some
patients however that will see very
limited changes in their PSA and
probably they already have a primary
resistance mechanism to unit two
antigens or two to androgen pop
modulation so again this resistance to
ADT to anything that involves the
antigen access can be relative to
antigen receptor mediated mechanisms
including mutations amplifications
splice variants you can get up
up-regulation again to other factors
that continue to drive the end within
the set and again though you can get you
can get with due to treatment pressure
selection you can get these androgen
receptor mediated mechanisms where you
get activation in the AR with all these
different types of mutations that you
discussed 5um again this was that same
paper that I was telling you about
earlier where you get glucocorticoid
receptor activation and this tends to
happen after
certain certain treatment so again this
is a very complex line so in summary
what's happening is that what used to be
all this we're all we really understood
was the role was the roll and the and
the continued requirement of the end of
interceptor what we're seeing now is all
these potential mechanisms that are that
are targets and so this is where a lot
of a lot of research is going and again
in in future how we're going to treat
advanced prostate cancer in the future
is really probably going to be looking
at novel mechanisms and we're going to
be you know we're going to need to be
targeting a lot of different areas you
know a lot of a lot of metastases in
prostate cancer is directed to with
metastatic disease to the bone so
manipulating the bone micro environment
as we know that one of the hot areas
right now across all tumor types is
looking at the immune system looking at
checkpoint inhibitors pd-1 and PDL one
inhibitors as well as ctla-4 but then
again all these different mutations that
happen within the prostate itself within
the primary that not only looking at the
antigen receptor but looking at all the
other of potential co-activators that
can that can continue to stimulate the
imaging accept it and have a state
catholics so that concludes my
presentation be happy to entertain any
questions that are out there any
comments thank you doctor can sub C on
for that very informative presentation
now we want to get right to your
questions and input so here's a reminder
of how to let us know what you have to
stay questions etc can be submitted via
the Q&A button at the lower left we will
try to get to all of you but if not we
will be sure to follow up after the
broadcast so let's get to our questions
okay dr. concept's young question number
one how many are actively treating mcrpc
patients within their practice well
again I think that in the New World
Order I think that historically speaking
prostate cancer has always been the
domain of the urologist as many of you
know we make the diagnosis of prostate
cancer because of the fact that patients
get referred to urologist by the primary
care because of an elevation in the PSA
now I think we as neurologist we need to
continue to refine PSA we know PSA by
itself is not a perfect test we know
that there are other ads event testing
both liquid urine and blood potentially
imaging that might help us but I think
with all these newer therapies I think
it's important especially as we get into
the changing environment and
reimbursement where neurologist I think
continue to need to be the lead not only
in diagnosing managing localized
prostate cancer but at the same time
even as they advance we need to be more
diligent in defining patients we maybe
have may be suffering or may may have
progressed the metastatic disease
because now we have all these new
therapies I think this needs to be a
multidisciplinary approach we need
radiation oncologists involved involved
we need medical oncologists but again i
really encourage the urology world to
want to try to really get a better
understanding of these of these
mechanisms and having out of best manage
these stations
next question are there any current
prostate cancer immune cells management
to resolution or cure
yeah that question really you know would
be interesting to hear from the from the
participants viewing how many are how
many urologists are out there and how
many of them are actively trying to
manage advance across the engineer
dr. Kentucky on how many urologists are
on the line no that's actually was one
of the question that that I opposed I
don't know if anybody if if any of the
audience wants to sort of give them self
up if you will and how many urologists
are out there and if this because again
as I just mentioned I think that this is
very important for the Europe for the
practicing neurologists and it's not
just for people in the academic settings
I believe as we see more and more
advanced prostate cancer everything that
we're talking about here all the newer
therapies it's important to understand
how they how they all how they all work
and the molecular mechanisms but there
are no more questions I would like to
once again thank dr. Ramos concepts
young for his presentation dr. detection
you
do you have any final comments for us
well and again I first of all I want to
thank everybody for jumping on this
morning this is a this is a new area I
try to make this somewhat simplified I
think again summary I think it's
important that we understand that the
antigen receptor still plays a role in
the progression but as we know there are
a number there are a number of
mechanistic actions both related to the
androgen receptor as well as the as non
AR mechanisms that that play a role and
I think they understand this disease
state you really have to understand all
the molecular mechanisms so it looks
like there's a question from the shell
from the shell will immunotherapy
address the polyclonal mechanisms of
metastatic cancer that's a great
question so the thing about
immunotherapies and so there is one
immunotherapy that's currently approved
for metastatic castration-resistant
prostate cancer which is so few lasell
to since the pool SLT is an autologous
in you know therapy where you where we
basically are stimulating the patient's
own immune cells in order to actually
treat the disease that's been improved
since nepal since april of 2010 since
the fuel SLT has been has been around
for a number of years and it's active in
you know therapy but it really should be
used very very early on in the diagnosis
and in the identification of metastatic
castration-resistant prostate cancer now
I think with some of the newer
immunotherapies and again much of this
is being directed towards these what we
call checkpoint inhibitors pd-1 PDL one
ctla-4 what the what those therapies are
trying to do is to unlock the immune
system the checkpoint inhibitor proteins
or the checkpoint proteins basically
the immune system intact and it also
prevents basically the immune system for
overly active so by blocking those
checkpoint proteins by using checkpoint
inhibitors then what you're doing is
that you're unleashing the immune system
the problem is is that not all prostate
cells basically will Express high
amounts of PDL one or ctla-4 so that's
the problem is that not all prostate
cancer by itself using immunotherapy by
itself it it won't be the complete
answer I think in the shell to answer
your question more appropriately I think
using immunotherapy in combination with
other therapies actually has a more
potential for essentially treating some
of these advanced states there is an
entity there's an entity out there
called the EBSCO pole effect in the
radiation therapists talk about this a
lot so the EBSCO pool effect is the use
of primary radiation which results in
cell kill and then antigen spread so in
theory what you could potentially do is
use systemic radiation say maybe even
radium-223 given in combination this
summit in is some of these immune
therapies as we talked about earlier as
I and I'm going to go back to this slide
that one of the things that's becoming
more germane is this concept of of small
clones within the prostate being the
clone that actually results in
metastatic disease and again when you
look at this particular slide when you
look at this particular schematic what
we also know is that some of these
metastatic sites can actually go back
and reseed the primary tumor so even in
the setting
there's a lot there's been a lot of
interest in this over the past couple
years even in the setting of metastatic
disease clearly all of the metastatic
disease low volume disease there is some
there are some studies now some there
are some theory some thoughts about
going ahead and aggressively treating
the primary whether that be removing
that surgically or radiating it to
prevent this to prevent this receding so
again I think immuno therapy lots of
interest and again a lot of this is
going to play out as we as we do more
studies looking at combinations and as
we get more aggressive in terms of doing
genomic sequencing not only at the
primary but as well as the next episodes
thank you again dr. Concepcion know if
we weren't able to speak directly with
you today we'll be sure to follow up
with you thank you for participating we
want to thank today's presenter as well
as lab rats calm the leading scientific
social networking site for more
information visit us at wwwbootysha
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing on our website to
februari 2017 we will let you know when
it's been posted and we hope you pass
that information on to any colleagues
who can it take part in today's
broadcast thanks for joining us we hope
to see you next time goodbye